I know that you you talk about your
phone and and how much use time you
spend on your phone when you're waiting
to work your Instagram you scream you do
some print again I watch you you you
like to post some weird stuff with your
friends what do ya mean - lately well
recently I don't have like a public
snapchat but I have one just purely for
the filters they're really fun I've been
doing a lot of face swapping it's really
cool to see you know what you'd look
like as a man or as your baby niece it's
it's actually really terrifying so I've
been doing a lot of that lately
okay I understand you you you wanted to
do that is that something I was
wondering if you and I could do it face
what I think you're gay I think you're
getting the bad end of this deal right
here I want I look like with your hair
okay well I could just take it off and
get down it's made of polyurethane am i
doing okay not sure I have no idea I
don't know anything about these okay
okay look at you this is fantastic
okay this is Face Swap and I just lean
in right here wait wait turn your head
this way
my turn turn like the same angles
wait a minute oh my god
[Applause]
that's how I look when I get up in the
morning first thing lightly like the
gremlin with I know it I think that just
makes what the evil within me
you